when I was with Tate I pulled him aside
so listen I I really like your brother
you know I really like how he is with
you you know Tristan I said but to me he
knows you're the alpha he says you think
so I don't know if you remember this I
said no I think he knows you're the
alpha and he gives you that respect
right even with DJ Khaled and who's the
other guy about Joe where Fat Joe says
khalid's younger than he's my young but
he's the alpha right each group has that
if you can find a friend like Joe but
there are good outfits in their battles
of course they're not there's a
difference the bad Alpha is a bully and
he's not dealing with the truth no he's
not good enough it keeps everybody they
keep them in line with the truth and
it's not about it's not about them like
he doesn't need the credit like a real
Alpha doesn't need other people to tell
him they're Alpha and hey I constantly
need confirmation you know a bad Alpha
needs constant confirmation a real Alpha
you don't need confidence